[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
can watch the Hall of Fame game
tomorrow night it'll be on NBC and
peacock they start at 7 Eastern Tony
Dungy would be part of the festivities a
Hall of Famer joining us from Canton
Ohio Tony looking good
long time no see uh do you have a Colts
jacket on there what uh any uh any teams
uh Hall of Fame oh oh okay and now is
your gold jacket there
it is yes I brought it this year oh okay
it's not like the Masters where you
leave your green jacket there you don't
no no no you get your key bit take it
around and a lot of people want you to
wear it to different events and it's uh
pretty cool how often how often do you
wear it socially
uh probably four or five times a year
just at Adventure that people ask you to
wear it or bring it it's not something I
just wear casually day to day but uh a
lot of people like to see it uh Todd uh
said that you were at the officiating
meeting uh so yeah what what's the uh
point of emphasis for officials this
upcoming season
a lot of player safety obviously uh just
looking at ways to make the game save
for a lot of discussion on the kickoff
kickoff's still the most dangerous play
percentage-wise in football uh there's a
lot of pushback from the Special Teams
coaches on Fair catching in the field of
play but I think the competition
committee again just trying to see how
they can make the game safer but they
wear these helmets these protective
shells in practice if they know that
helps protect the players then why don't
they div why don't they make a helmet so
they can wear that in the game Tony
you're reading my mind that was a
question I asked the NFL office they
showed us this data that players wore
these shells in practice reduced
concussions 22 percent in practice if
I'm a player I would say if that's true
let me wear it in the game and they
should be allowed to wear it in the game
I don't know if that's coming but that
was the exact question I asked yeah I I
watch it and it looks odd but I think
anything you know sometimes we'll see
things and go oh my gosh that's odd I'm
sure that the guys who played with uh
you know helmets with no face mask
looked at guys wearing a face mask and
go boy that looks weird and then all of
a sudden hockey players had to wear a
helmet or running backs were wearing
shields on you know all these things
that seem like they're strange can can
they design a helmet that you could wear
the helmet and it's gonna if you know
further ensure safety
absolutely and that's what we should be
after and yes it doesn't look good it
doesn't look as cool but if I'm a 25
year old player and I'm going to play 10
years and I'm going to take
200 hits to the Head during the course
of my career and this is going to give
me uh a 50 less chance to have a
concussion I would do it
uh help me understand the coaching
Community Sean Payton has his comments
about Nathaniel Hackett and uh Hackett
of course now with the Jets and Sean
taking over in Denver
what what do you think the strategy was
if there was with Sean to say this
well I think the strategy was I'm going
to prop up my team I'm going to build up
my guys that are here you weren't as bad
as people thought last year I'm behind
you uh I'm with you and you we all do
that in private I was very surprised
that Sean took it public hey when I went
to the Tampa Bay Buccaneers in 1996.
Warren Sapp was his rookie year being
taken out on third down John Lynch was a
backup linebacker and Derrick Brooks was
playing over the tight end getting
swallowed by 250 pound tight ends
I told those guys
we've got a different system now you
guys will fit this like a glove you
should be multi-year pro bowlers but I
didn't go out and say oh these guys were
used wrongly this was poor coaching no I
mean you say that to your players and
you build them up but there's a certain
respect for each other in the game that
you don't say that publicly
well it's like remember when you were
doing football night in America and we
were we were showing clips of Rex Ryan
and hard knocks and you came out and
said that he could never coach on your
staff or be part of your staff and that
almost felt like it broke the code that
you were talking out of school about
another coach even though you weren't
coaching anymore
right and that's what
I think that's the difference and Sean
said well I had my box hat on well you
you aren't working for Fox now and I I
got paid to say things like that I still
get paid to give my opinion and that's
tough you know you you don't always want
to do that but you have to be on and
you're the best at it because you had
asked me questions you know I'm not
going to lie to you so you can ask me
questions to put me on the spot but
that's my job at that point but I I
would certainly answer differently if I
was coaching as opposed to broadcasting
how do you think hard knocks impacts the
Jets
uh I I think they've got enough
professionals that they you know they
get around it I would have never wanted
to be on Hard Knocks I I think anytime
you introduce the cameras it brings
another element to the game that you
really don't want another distraction
you have to be careful about what you
say your quarterbacks have to be careful
about what they talk about all those
things so but I I think the Jets are
approaching this really well and
professionally and they're they're going
to be okay I I just to me it was a a
worry that I never wanted in training
camp talking to Tony Dungy Hall of Fame
head coach we had Steve Young on last
week and he said that this would have
been his era like this style of football
would have been great for Steve Young
because he would have been encouraged to
run and he was also a great passer but
he said something that really stood out
he said the days of Dan Marino and
Peyton Manning are done at that position
I I think he's right and I remember when
I was a young coach and I would do
college clinics and talk about all these
defenses that we ran and the college
coaches would always end well what if
the quarterback runs what do you do and
I wanted to say we don't worry about
that because no one runs well now all of
a sudden you bring that element into it
and you get a Patrick Mahomes that you
defend everything right John Elway was
the first one he gave me headaches that
way you defend everything he moves
around for 10 seconds hits a guy down
the field or runs for 20 yards and it
breaks down your whole defense well now
you've got to deal with these
quarterbacks that run there's it
restricts what you can play defensively
it helps the receivers it helps
everything and that mobile quarterback
has an advantage and coaches understand
that now so they're not telling the guy
oh Fran tarkness stay in the pocket
don't scramble they're saying oh no this
is an advantage yeah well could you see
a team featuring a running game and
de-emphasizing throwing the ball 30
times
no I I think you're beyond that just
with the way the rules are it's so easy
to throw now and you're getting these
great receivers you're getting
quarterbacks who've thrown the ball
thousands of times in college uh and so
you've got to utilize that and it is the
way to strike quickly now you got to
have a running game you look at all
these teams that have won the Super
Bowls the last 15 years you've got to be
able to run but
throwing the ball scoring points that's
the way the league is set up now
if I said you could put one player in
the Hall of Fame who's not in the Hall
of Fame
who would it be wow there there's a lot
of guys uh this senior class this year
that's going in I'm really happy for
some of those guys uh Albert Lewis is
I'm I'm kind of on that bandwagon I
Coach Albert Lewis for three years uh he
was incredible and
um he doesn't get the credit because we
didn't win a bunch of Super Bowls we
didn't have the we played in a small
Market but he was probably the best
one-on-one cover guy I've ever been
around
if you were coaching Peyton and going
against Darrell Rivas do you have to
tell him we're not going in that
direction
no there's certain things and and he
would do it I mean he'd stay away from
you if he had a better matchup somewhere
else he'd go there I can remember
playing against Champ Bailey and Reggie
Wayne catches 12 balls for 200 something
yards we only threw two balls to Marvin
that week because we had a successful
match-up but now if they're going to tip
everything over away from Bailey or away
from Rivas and say we're just going to
leave him one-on-one then then you've
got to take some shots over there but um
it it really is where do you have the
best chance to succeed and most of the
time with Rebus it's with going after
the other guy yeah but I I don't think
Peyton would admit that he would have
stayed away from Darrell like he
wouldn't say that publicly do you think
no he would just say we had better
options and that's what he said we threw
15 balls of rock Alexander made 250
yards I don't need to throw a Champ
Bailey but now if you help Alexander and
you tip the coverage over there and you
make me throw a Bailey we've got some
things that we can do and that that's
the way Peyton would approach it but he
would be smart and he would just pick
his spots when you coached Peyton were
you faster than Peyton
um
probably the first part of my career yes
if you ran out of the end but at the
beginning oh no Peyton at the end
against you at the end
40-yard dash well yes and and I got
there in 2002 I might have been able to
get in by 2007 or 2008 I could
what is what is the biggest concern or
team looking at this year of just you
know we've talked about Buffalo that
window here they've they've lost some
starters it feels like it's now to win
uh the Bengals uh are they going to be
able to keep all those receivers is that
window now Kansas City we know that
window is now Philadelphia's in that
window is Dallas in that window the
Niners in that window it feels like you
got seven or eight teams now we should
be thinking about the Super Bowl
yeah you do and I heard you asked the
question in the previous do you talk
about yes you talk about it that's our
goal and we want to win it you mentioned
Cincinnati they still got Joe burrow on
that first contract that's when you got
a strike you look at all these
quarterbacks the Russell Wilson's uh you
know you you win when you've got that
great quarterback on his first contract
now when you have to pay him you're
going to start losing players and that's
going to make it more difficult so yeah
I think one Cincinnati is a team that I
think needs to strike
when's the last time you asked a Hall of
Famer for an autograph
um
I got Earl Campbell A couple of years
ago from my brother-in-law my
brother-in-law just loves Earl and so
hey Earl I don't like to do this
I need you
um how's Earl doing he's last time I saw
him last year he had the Walker and
that's tough to see it really is but uh
he was he was gracious and and still
funny and and doing well yeah like I saw
him years ago and and he was in a
wheelchair and yeah you know you just
look look you know that's why we talk
about running backs getting paid I mean
nobody takes more of a beating than they
do but uh I I just can't imagine how
anybody changes anything with this if
let's say you're you're coaching Josh
Jacobs what would you say to Josh Jacobs
you have to play ball and you have to
strike while the Iron's hot and you get
as much as you can get I I talked about
this on social media the other day uh
Mike Flora made a comment about it it's
not new uh to the our Super Bowl year
Adrian James was going to be a free
agent he had come back from knee surgery
had a 1500 yard year for us in 2005 best
running back that I've been around in
terms of doing everything running
running inside outside catching the ball
pass protection and a phenomenal
teammate Bill Poland says we either have
to sign edrin before he gets the free
agency because once he gets on the
market we're not going to afford him
we'll have to get him at a deal less
than he should deserve
or we can let him go
it's going to be a great year for
running backs we'll get Maurice Jones
Drew Joseph Addai or Laurence Maroney
for much less money and then we'll take
that extra money and we'll resign Dwight
Freeney Dallas Clark and Reggie Wayne
wow well that was a tough deal and edrin
was the heart and soul of our team after
I slept on it for three or four days and
talked with Jim birth you know we have
to do that so we went to Ezra and hey
we're going to let you go he got paid
big money by Arizona but we had another
running back come in not Ezra and James
but played well enough for us to go to
the Super Bowl and then State as a Super
Bowl Contender for a number of years
just because you use your money wisely
and that's what you have to do and
that's what I tell Josh Jacobs hey you
you got to play and it's not fair but
that's life
good to talk to you and uh have fun
there in Canton hopefully it's not too
hot with the Hall of Fame induction
ceremonies
yeah it's it's in the afternoon again
Ronde Barber my one of my former players
is going in so looking forward to it hey
great to talk to you Tony thank you
thanks deeply yep Tony Dungy Hall of
Famer joining us from Canton Ohio